the 1980s launched a ton of cartoon
franchises only to see many of them
cancelled mysteriously was it because of
network politics slow toy sales are just
sheer foolishness it turns out it was
often all of those things and more
long before every other podcast started
to feature minor celebrities playing
Dungeons & Dragons kids could watch
Dungeons & Dragons the cartoon on CBS
Saturday mornings the show followed a
group of young teenagers stranded in the
realm of Dungeons and Dragons
they each played a role like Ranger
barbarian or thief and tried to get home
while helping the realm
it was the highest-rated show in its
timeslot for two years and it lasted
three seasons before cancellation rumors
built up over the years about why the
show was cut with the violent content
and the moral panic surrounding D&D
considered possible culprits a partial
answer came from writer Michael Reeves
who claimed unfortunately problems with
TSR the D&D parent company ultimately
killed the plans for a new season Mark
Evanier who helped develop the show for
TV and wrote the first few episodes
finally set the record straight in 2012
by pointing the finger at declining
ratings he explained as far as I know
the protests were minimal and had no
impact the show simply began losing its
audience as all shows eventually do
Robocop isn't the most violent movie to
be adapted into a cartoon for children
that honor Shirley goes to the rambo
series which birth rambo the force of
freedom but Robocop is a solid second
sure the movie itself had plenty of
Titian's but it's still a hard-r action
movie nevertheless Robocop the animated
series existed in 1988 and had a solid
following the show did make several
alterations in the name of being
kid-friendly such as replacing bullets
with laser beams the original plan was
to run for 13 episodes in syndication
until the budget for episode 13 was
rerouted so the series finished at
episode 12 with the money for the plan
finale going instead towards Pryde of
the x-men the pilot for an x-men series
while there would be many x-men cartoons
over the years Pryde never came to
fruition meaning one cartoon was
canceled and a failed attempt to start
another the title GI Joe a real American
hero can refer to two separate shows the
first is the series made by son Bo
productions that ran from 1983 to 1986
the second is the one made by di C that
ran from 1989 to 1992 why was there a
gap between two Studios telling one
continuous story it turns out that the
first edition was cancelled after a
bidding war after producing the first
two seasons of the show Sun Bo had
detailed plans in place for a third the
Joe's would go off to fight a new foe
called the coil while Cobra Commander
would be in the background biding his
time until he could play the coil and
the Joe's off each other before this
could happen though Hasbro changed
things up the toy company had been
self-funding the show with son Bo and
decided to cut production costs
according to GI Joe's story editor buzz
Dixon the syndication market was
saturated in the mid 80s with more shows
than their work time slots available di
C was a big part of this problem often
under bidding competitors all this led
to Hasbro deciding to cut costs by
dumping son Bo after di C offered them a
contract to good reviews Dixon has no
kind words for di C to this day as he
put it in an interview these guys may
not have been 100% responsible for the
destruction of the animation industry in
the late 80s but they sure helped based
on the long-running comic strip Garfield
and friends was a massive success
worldwide and featured some of the best
animation of its era it lasted seven
seasons and eternity in 80s cartoon
years it was finally canceled in 1994
because of budget cuts due to a changing
TV landscape the show was expensive to
produce but the producers figured that
it was worth it selling the show to CBS
and in syndication deals across the
country let them charge a high license
fee and rake in profits success up the
license fee each year and eventually CBS
wanted to renegotiate when Garfield and
friends premiered cartoons aired almost
exclusively on CBS ABC and NBC as the
series went on however Fox became a
viable network and entire channels
dedicated to animation like Cartoon
Network popped up more places to watch
cartoons meant that the audience was
spreading thinner which meant networks
became stingy ER CBS asked the producers
to cut the show's budget by two-thirds
figuring that they made enough in
syndication to handle a smaller cash
flow but the producers did the math and
determined that it wouldn't work
syndication wasn't going to cover the
deficit costs and the show was doing
well enough in reruns so Garfield and
friends was cancelled I don't have to
put up with this
plenty of people who'd love to have a
cat especially one as adorable as me
Voltron was one of the most popular
cartoons of the eighties spawning a
franchise that exists to this day and
its peak it was the number one
syndicated children's show in America
after the second season plans for
another were in place but they never
materialized there were several reasons
for this but it all boils down to two
major producers having a falling-out
Voltron started because producer Ted
coppler realized there was a market for
adapting foreign children's shows to the
American market he hired Peter O'Keefe
an energetic man with a real talent for
the business to help localize Voltron
for a couple of anime shows and run
production but the tensions boiled
between the two and it all came to a
head in 1989 when O'Keefe sued coppler
over breach of contract as O'Keefe felt
that he was owed more money bitter
feelings persisted until the two men
reconciled around 2010 just before
O'Keefe passed away it was that peace
that paved the way for today's modern
Voltron properties Thundarr the
Barbarian followed Thunder and his
friends across a post-apocalyptic earth
the show was created by ruby-spears
productions in 1980 and comics legend
Jack Kirby helped with the design of the
show it was ostensibly a children's show
but the writers aim for slightly older
audiences despite its popularity it was
canceled after two seasons in 1981 joe
ruby 1/2 and the namesake of ruby-spears
had his own ideas about why as he put it
it was not canceled from a lack of
ratings I'll tell you that right off the
top it was cancelled I guess because it
was to violence or something like that
that may well have been part of it but
there was an even bigger factor in play
Gary Marshall wanted its slot
Marshall oversaw ABC's three biggest
shows at the time Happy Days Laverne and
Shirley and Mork and Mindy what he
wanted the network gave him and what
Marshall wanted was animated versions of
his shows so as to cover every possible
audience thus to make room for Fonz and
the Happy Days gang Thunder was kicked
from the airwaves funds in the Happy
Days gang was gone one year later and a
series of shows based on other Marshall
properties took its place none did as
well as Thundarr though the danger is
over for now sunday funnies mainstay
Heathcliff appeared in two cartoon
adaptations by two Studios two years
apart the first simply titled Heathcliff
was created by ruby-spears productions
and ran on ABC
from 1980 to 1981 the second best known
as Heathcliff and the Cadillac cats was
produced by D IC and ran in syndication
from 1984 through 1985 there hasn't been
a new Heathcliff cartoon since because
of the loss of legendary lead voice
actor Mel Blanc in an era when most
voice acting was done by character
actors an anonymous voice-over artist
flanked was a legitimate superstar on
par with anyone at Hollywood he was the
voice of Bugs Bunny Daffy Duck and many
others including Heathcliff on both of
the cats shows Blanc was also a heavy
smoker he smoked a pack a day from when
he was nine until he was 77 he quit
after developing emphysema and spent
most of his last decade revisiting
characters he had played for years
Heathcliff was his last new character
according to Donna Christie who voiced
Iggy and Cleo on Heathcliff in the
Cadillac cats the show ended because
blanc became too ill to keep doing it
his death in 1989 meant that nobody had
any reason to make more Heathcliff
episodes any attempts to revive the show
later were pointless as nobody could
follow Blanc most of the shows on this
list were cancelled after they got
popular but the Garbage Pail Kids was
popular entirely because it was
cancelled before a single episode had
even aired in fact the Garbage Pail Kids
brand started as trading cards that were
created as a parody of the Cabbage Patch
Kids the Garbage Pail Kids were
chock-full of gross-out humor and they
stirred up a decent amount of
controversy in their heyday take a card
any card you'll probably wish you hadn't
terry Drinkwater explains that american
children these days are obsessed with
the whole disgusting deck when word got
out that there was going to be a cartoon
based on the cards morality enforcers
swooped in to strike the National
Federation for decency took off arms
with particular zeal these protests led
to advertisers backing out and some
affiliates refusing to air the show
ultimately CBS pulled the plug on the
Garbage Pail Kids before it could air in
America they attempted to sanitize the
show but it just didn't work the show
aired in several other countries and
gained a cult following through bootlegs
and eventually a proper DVD release one
unlikely person who was happy to see it
cancelled was Mark Newgarden who was
part of the team that created the
trading cards he said I've seen the
pilot episode and it's a lame castrated
version of the Garbage Pail Kids
carefully avoiding everything that made
our cards work
and humanoids followed a team of Earth
Sciences fighting off the title
subterranean beasts it ran for 13
episodes in syndication and was noted
for its monstrous designs and surprising
amount of violence though it had a
following it was cancelled after one
season due to a few factors particularly
money the show also generated some
protests due to its brutality which
certainly contributed to the
cancellation while opposition of this
nature didn't help matter as the nail in
the coffin could be found in the toy
aisle like many cartoons of the era and
humanoids was designed to sell toys
there was just one problem the toy line
bombed the toys were large in size heavy
and too grotesque to be mainstream
they were so top-heavy in fact that they
were infamous for falling over the show
also appealed to a slightly older
audience one that tends to be less
interested in toys clearly not much was
expected at the toy line either as the
show was cancelled before the toys were
even released though it's mostly
remembered for its live-action bit
starring Lou albano as Mario and Danny
Welles as Luigi the Super Mario Brothers
Super Show was half cartoon the show is
nevertheless labor intensive for the
actors who had to work six days a week
to produce a new episode every single
weekday it was a huge hit with kids who
were almost certainly thrilled that they
could get their fix at video games and
cartoons from the same source at the end
of the first season order a Nintendo
simply didn't have any more interest in
the show and didn't renew their
agreement with DI si for it in 1990
Nintendo and di C teamed up again for
The Adventures of Super Mario Brothers 3
doing essentially the same show but
without the live-action bits that show
didn't last very long either as only
thirteen episodes were produced check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]